what what what is going on here the
bitcoin bowls are bad yeah look you know
yesterday simi Bitcoin futures 1.2
billion dollars in volume a lot of these
exchanges are seeing all-time highs in
volume and I think that we've seen the
bottom of the bear market and who are
these people
yeah I think there's two things so one
definitey institutions are starting to
come in you see fidelity announcing that
they're going to start their custody and
trading backed us at the deadline for
July but retail also is coming in right
and I think what you're seeing is two
things
one it's a very scarce asset we're about
a year out from the happening so it's
gonna get about half as scarce in the
monetary schedule it sounds really
exciting
the so historically that's been a big
moment in terms of it really is a price
driver because it reminds people that
there's only 21 million if there's just
an arbitrary thing right to cut it in
half in terms of the unit's preset every
four years basically the amount that is
created every ten minutes gets cut in
half so right now it's 12 and a half
Bitcoin every ten minutes in may twenty
twenty it'll get cut to six point two
five so if you believe in scarce assets
that's a big moment and we're about a
year out from that and then the other
thing I'd say is I think that the trade
war actually has a little bit to do with
it right this idea that we're watching
you know essentially a trade war play
out on Twitter you look at a
non-sovereign currency and and I think
that there's some kind of safety that
around though if this trade bore gets
solved does Bitcoin go down it could
right I think that the big thing here is
if you look at the macro trend Bitcoin
has seen three draw downs over eighty
percent in its lifetime the last decade
but it is the best performing asset and
one of the core layers I draw is if you
look at Amazon stock right so Amazon's
drawn down over 90 percent twice the
entry a year draw down is over 30
percent on average right so it's a
pretty volatile stock in that sense
bitcoins done very similar things but
what it continues to do is set new
yearly lows right so don't look at the
highs look at the lows and again it's
just supply and demand if you have a
scarce asset and demand increases mr.
wonderful things it's worthless well I
call it garbage to explore the I did say
I want to explore the idea that there's
nothing here except Ross speculation no
different that when I go to Las Vegas
and put my money on black or red on a
roulette
because where is the intrinsic value
inherent in deploying real capital let's
talk real money here and putting it into
Bitcoin as a storage of value I get gold
for 2,000 years including the Romans
they saw value in owning that as an
asset class tell me why this which is
basically a digital game where I look at
it has any intrinsic value with people
actually put real money into this they
make no interest they can't pay their
taxes with it the regulator's don't like
it which is always a problem for
compliance and where's the long-term
value just this this idea that they're
gonna cut the number of units in half
cents is such a scam that's just totally
BS so I would say two things one is it's
disruptive technology so if you look at
it from a technology standpoint that
also has an odor of BS to it it look
everything that's new seems different
right in the beginning and I think what
you've gotta realizes with Bitcoin
specifically money is a belief system so
the US dollar the only reason why you
and I use it is because we believe it
has value so I give you a dollar you
give me a good or service in exchange
where you believe that it has value
Bitcoin has value because two people who
exchange it believe it has that value
and what we're seeing is the volume
right look at people using it but that's
the ultimately what matters other crypto
crap there's lots of other coins I
believe Bitcoin is the king and is gonna
stay the king for a very long time so I
taught a class at Harvard 18 months ago
that young people in that class
challenged me I put a hundred dollars
into something called coinbase uses a
wallet thing and you buy Bitcoin I
bought it all I bought all the crypto
crap I've got a hundred dollars in it's
now worth thirty thirty it's a seventy
percent loss on my crypto crap now I
bought them all I think that really
sucks and I think people should
understand today the the hot digital is
Bitcoin tomorrow it could be whatever
right again I think that Bitcoin the
reason why bitcoin is getting so much
attention it's the best performing asset
in the last decade right it's
drastically outperformed SPE every other
kind of financial asset that's out there
and the second thing is the institutions
are coming in because bitcoin is
actually a better store of value it's
more transparent and more secure so
regulators they actually
like Bitcoin in the sense of law
enforcement can track criminal activity
right every single transaction is done
on a public ledger he can see law
enforcement loves Bitcoin I I've
interviewed a DEA agent who came on and
they would love for criminals to use
Bitcoin over u.s. dollars in cash right
it's much more traceable and so what law
enforcement is saying is they want these
digital currencies used Bitcoin
specifically because of the public
public nature of the transactions easier
to track the criminal activity after the
fact after the fact yeah of course
well US dollars you can't track it
before or after last time this had a big
run up to twenty thousand and people
started talking about assets with it the
SEC where he was handing out subpoenas
like birthday cards they were doing it
for the IC OS so I SEOs are essentially
people who took the concept of a
blockchain or a crypto currency token
and they're using it for fundraising for
companies and so you can imagine if you
go out and solicit funds from investors
and you do know various things yes he
cares I mean the fact that matters is
Bitcoin has been acting written pretty
well in in respect to the recent bad
news hitting the sector we had a hack of
Finance and then we also have the New
York AG bringing charges against tether
and BitFenix and the coin has done most
of us are more currency why can't I pay
my taxes with it can the IRS take you
can in the state of Ohio they accept
Bitcoin as for taxes and there's other
states that are working on it now
federal you think it'll ever get there
for sure well you're an optimist Wayne
when I'm not in the business of making
bets on the federal government's
regulatory we hit the pass highs again I
definitely think that we will write
against this sort of timeframe look at
that's the hard part the way that I
think to look at this it's a
non-correlated asymmetric return asset
and we definitely in my opinion we've
hit the bottom of the bear market we've
now entered into this bull market
historically about a year out from that
havening period is when that kicks off
it wouldn't surprise me if we enter a
kind of a two to three-year bull market
now and 20,000 I think will be a blip on
the radar just like previous past highs
we're only Bitcoin only Bitcoin a lot of
the crypto crap I'm not here to talk
about anything else but Bitcoin it seems
like you would think that if it's all
boats would rise in this type of crypto
so for your portfolio here's the number
one thing I can tell you as to why you
should own Bitcoin
it's a non-correlated asymmetric return
asset that the value drivers of all of
your equities everything else is tied to
earnings GDP interest rates etc as a
bitcoin it's not tied to anything well
neither is US dollars and how big is
your cash position you know I I look I
love your optimistic view of it you
haven't changed my mind at all it's
still a car Bob and I'm not gonna take
real money and put it into this thing
it's never gonna happen real dollars
that I'm making in cash two point one
percent on I'm putting in it's a crypto
crap agree to disagree
absolutely okay so your crypto crap
garbage garbage is better than garbage
you keep saying that cool money take a
little colorful language is necessary
when discussing Bitcoin about it Anthony
thank you
you